well there are seven dead in another
mass shooting this one in California now
what's confusing and I admit it's it is
confusing this is not the mass shooting
from a few days ago this is a different
California mass shooting and uh BBC News
has a brief article about it Half Moon
Bay seven dead in another California
mass shooting the U.S state of
California is reeling from its third
mass shooting in eight days after a man
shot dead seven former co-workers South
of San Francisco this was in Half Moon
Bay some of the victims were
chinese-american the suspect Chun Li
Zhao 66 years old was arrested after
driving to a police station this is
remember separate from the death of 11
people in Monterey Park which is six
hours southeast of Half Moon Bay and
just over a week ago six people
including a teenage mother and baby were
killed at a property in Goshen in
central California now there there have
been 40 mass shootings in the United
States this year so far let me make sure
I'm being clear about that mass
shootings if you want to know how many
shootings have there been it's hundreds
hundreds hundreds but if we limit it to
mass shootings there have been 40. this
year and it is of course the 25th of
January so more than one per day you can
find information about them on the gun
violence archive they have a category
called mass shootings they also have a
separate category for all shootings
which you can find and uh you will see
um the shooting I just mentioned listed
Half Moon Bay since this incident
yesterday there were two more mass
shootings including uh not including the
two those two shootings were in Oakland
California one killed four injured and
in Red Springs North Carolina three
killed and one injured also listed here
from a few days ago is the Monterey Park
shooting 12 dead 9 injured we're out of
ideas is guys we don't know how to
prevent this of course this is the only
country where this happens with this
regularity but we have absolutely no
idea how to prevent it we're all out of
ideas even though we haven't really
tried anything yet and I think this is
as good a time as any
to remind everyone's memory uh refresh
everyone's memory of the list I provided
who knows after which mass shooting
maybe this was after a Texas mass
shooting a year ago it's constant so I
don't know when I last showed you this
list it's probably been about a year we
have things that we can do and what I
would immediately do if things were up
to me and again remember this is all
without displacing the second amendment
that we have a second amendment none of
my suggestions here say get rid of the
Second Amendment but here are things we
could immediately do end the Gun Show
loophole which refers to the fact that
federal law doesn't require unlicensed
private sellers to do a background check
if you just privately sell a gun and
someone shows up to get it you are not
required as an unlicensed private seller
to have a background check done on that
individual that's a horrifying loophole
we should have Universal background
checks which would require just about
every Firearms transaction
to go through the nics national instant
criminal background check system and
that would close what is sometimes
called the private sale exemption
Universal background checks are not
required by federal law there are 22
States in DC which do require them at
least for some private sales but is not
nearly Universal there should be a
mandatory waiting period from when you
purchase the gun to when you actually
get the gun there should be no high
capacity weapons sold to anybody under
age 25 you should be required to have
gun insurance and it should be
significantly more expensive without a
parent if you were under 25 if you're
under 25 and you want a gun you should
be required to get Community Support
letters from adults in your community
that can say I know this person and I
have no concerns about them having a
firearm some weapons should be banned I
mean there are some weapons that they're
they're of no recreational or other
value than as mass killing machines they
aren't uh valuable as in terms of sport
or hunting I'm not pretending I have the
full list right now but there should be
some weapons banned you should be
required to have a periodic mental
health evaluation and the licensing
process itself to even get the license
to get the gun in the first place should
be significantly more extensive there
should be a written and practical test
like for a driver's license there should
be a training and Licensing period that
isn't just one weekend it should be
longer like with vehicles and we should
also have a gun buyback program give
people an off-ramp that feels better
then we're going to be confiscating guns
now I know every time I present this
list someone writes and says David that
wouldn't have stopped this specific
shooter or that specific shooter well
but it might stop the next one
and it would have stopped some of them
if we think of each shooting that has
taken place in almost every case some of
these items would have been relevant
some of these items not all
and it would still be a worthy cause to
reduce the number of mass shootings it's
January 5th and we've had 40 mass
shootings in the United States so that
is a list that every time I look at it
continues to make a lot of sense some of
these items there actually is
significant National support for some of
them there is not necessarily
um but we have things we can try
and so far the things that have been
done uh other than that period when
there was an assault weapons ban in the
90s and there was a reduction in mass
shootings during that period of time
nothing else seems to uh prayers aren't
helping fixing doors isn't helping
um triple pane windows are not helping
right I mean the things that the right
talks about aren't helping and then
lastly the right says oh Mental Health
they also don't want to fund
um making the mental health support
system in this country more robust so
they're also Hypocrites as far as that
goes